[Musique]
bon de la réunion bonjour le monde
comment il est tout autre les biens mal
et mieux regarde ça commençait joli ici
et on est haut et bas on est à saint leu
pourquoi nous les à saint leu nous les à
saint leu pour a rencontré un monsieur
qui fait des oeuvres d'art de bijoux en
en en écaille
oui pas dit quels poissons marins à
l'est pas 3 1
un rouge offert un bijou avec non avec
des écailles de tortue avec des
carapaces de tortues c'est toujours lui
c'est tout mignon
j'éprouve en main ces croisements
sérieusement pour la peine je viens on
va voir s'il manathan avec un autre
vinci
au japon on est assis
il ya la piscine
mettez qui tient
[Musique]
bon génie qu'on vole toujours comme on
est des plaines est la même au super
génial déjà maire
écoute via nos immigrés est ce que tu
fais voilà donc ici moi je travaille
différentes matières sur plus souvent
des matières qui vient de la mer donc
les cailles qui la matière noble 2
que je travaille après s'est associé
avec de la laque pour différents objets
et de l'anacr de leurs mots durs offrent
d'espagne en finlande et des morceaux de
coquillages ou autres est ce que je me
donnais ma jolie petite pièce en
perspective je crois que là ça va être
un plaisir pour les yeux alors tu nous
montres tout ça très vite parce que moi
je suis pressé de voir ça nous obliger à
balan à londres alors pour aller à la
table on y va
juste un peu
juste un peu tourné
passé
je me sers
je vous le jure il est insu
ici maintenant qu'on va travailler sur
sur des carapaces donc là vous avez là
la carapace brut d'accord non seulement
ça
la carapace qui est brut dis moi c'est
une tortue qui soit des petites tortues
comme ça je pense qu'il peut être qu'il
est entre deux ans et demi trois ans
peut-être
ou plus est ce que chaque carapace selon
des variétés à une particularité
alors chaque tortue est une pièce unique
il faut savoir à 30 g de la naissance
ils ont déjà déterminé lors de leurs
nuances
il faut savoir que la tortue verte on
appelle la 38 verte ou la 38 franche
c'est une tortue qu'on va pêcher pour la
viande non pas portion des cayes ne
commence qu'à l'état sauvage shanghai
n'a aucun intérêt marche en avant oui ça
qu'il faut le savoir parce que cette
fortune par contre à l'iphone qui est
excellent et ça c'est le nom du coin ça
c'est la tortue verte où je l'appelle la
tortue
[Musique]
ouazzani
mon ami et manille
subit là là on a déjà fini de passer le
le papier ces gens qu'on arrive à ce
stade là c'est très joli
on se regardait ça mais c'est très joli
c'est très joli et en plus là c'est pas
vraiment travailler ça veut dire que
c'est juste bon c'est bien c'est propre
mais ensuite il ya encore des petits
vernis du cirage où je sais ça alors
soit ces vernis ou soit c'est poli
toutes les carapaces et les écailles que
vous voyez là datent d'avant 84 donc
soit c'est une 82 83 alors celui ci par
exemple à l'été du 6 12 82 et comme nous
on a eu la chance à la réunion d'avoir
un élevage qui a permis
aujourd'hui devenu un centre
scientifique et pédagogique qui permet
des gens qui viennent de toute l'europe
et d'ailleurs de voir des tortues de
près aujourd'hui je travaille
l'esprit tranquille parce que on est sur
les carapaces on un certificat
intracommunautaire qu'on délivre à la
vente et sur les objets on a des petits
certificat qui accompagne tous les
objets qui est vendu donc une
traçabilité de savoir qui a vendu quoi
s'il ya un contrôle qui se fait en
quittant le territoire ou en arrivant
sur un attentat territoire pas
d'affolement toujours bien voilà il est
dans les normes
[Musique]
donc le cd bijoux voilà alors c'est
tekaya elle peut être utilisée sur un
coffret en création d'un couteau n'ouvre
lettres bijoux stylo
[Musique]
les sudafs vous voyez ça d'accord elle à
nicole va nous faire un bracelet wpt il
est capable notamment un petit peu les
différentes étapes pour faire un
bracelet avec ça s'il te plaît donc là
on a au départ passer un petit coup de
ponçage pour enlever le
le plus d'impuretés qu'il ya maintenant
on regarde le maximum d'épaisseur donc
on va utiliser pareil ce petit grattoir
qui est très important pendez juste les
impuretés vous pour éviter de si on
utilise une machine ça va user sur les
extrémités et ça va pas être bien pour
le faire donc on est obligé de le faire
la marche turque l'a donc là ce qu'on va
faire on fait des copeaux de bois
c'est fou et tu passes toutes les pièces
tu les tuez pas sauvés a mis tout ce que
tu disais tout à l'heure alors tout ce
qui est passé au vernis c'est les
carapaces parce que c'est les gens vont
l'essuyer dans le vanni et en matière
qui est assez résistant donc sa garde le
brillance et nuances plus longtemps que
si on avait poli par contre tout ce qui
est bijouteries ces politiques là on va
utiliser de papier c'est que si vous
passez le doigt ou santé des
irrégularités voilà exactement donc là
on le sent bien et le 220 on va enlever
au tout ça et on va utiliser le 6 ans
pour enlever les rayures du 220 donc on
va garder les rieurs le plus fine dessus
comme ça quand on va le polir le
polissage vont enlever les rayons de
l'homme dessus il exactement mais le
ponçage est très important s'il va avoir
un polissage qui soit une pièce qu'ils
soient bien fini votre bas si on a un
mauvais passage ça on va le regarder si
le le ponçage qu'on a fait est bon
normalement on un professionnel l'a pas
dit ces matières vivantes
donc on a toujours des surprises oui bon
c'est oui normalement ça doit aller
alors alors monsieur ben écoute pour
l'instant cette partie là est très bien
ici aussi
donc là on peut passer
[Musique]
là on va le faire taire on a créé un
petit peu comment on va les mettre en
forme a molli un peu en fait trois
avocats vie des bonbons à la je pense
que ça doit être bon à tirer
ouais ça va arriver bientôt
donc là on va utiliser le le gabarit là
je vais le laisser comme ça pendant une
semaine et demi et après je viens je
vais commencer à leur travail et après
je vais laisser encore séché et revenir
dessus
enfin quand on a trois fous trois étapes
de qu'on va revenir dessus d'après celle
là après celle la finition la finition
c'est très très très important
[Musique]
alors donc là c'est la mode bracelets
dont corps et celui là par exemple il
était mise en forme mais on la veut dire
lâché un petit peu trop tôt donc il ya
le cd former un nouveau donc là ce qu'on
va faire on va lui redonner sa forme
initiale
on va chauffer ici de chaque côté avec
moi connaissons pouvoir qu'il garde sa
forme
[Musique]
là pour le coup tu en train de scotch et
pour redonner le la forme du bracelet en
fait exactement comme on a chauffé de
chaque côté on va le coincer pour
qu'elles gardent cette forme ovale noval
voilà pour bien prendre en fait le
poignet de votre joli thing madame aude
jolie petite fille ou deux petits
garçons 1 n'est ce pas ou pour moi
j'aime bien les bracelets comme ça
[Musique]
jamin il veut savoir comment la
commencer quoi là pour sauver ce métier
voilà je veux tout savoir de ta passion
qui est ton métier vaut le coup c'est ce
métier chez arrivée dedans par hasard
j'ai appris qu'il va y avoir une
formation sur le travail de les cayes à
saint leu quand j'ai découvert la
matière moi j'appelle ça toujours la
matière magique et là je suis resté
dedans donc ça fait au total je veux
dire plus les formations post le travail
chez l'artisan au chez qui j'ai
travaillé au départ au ca va faire 35
ans que je suis dans ce métier là dont
30 ans mon compte j'ai vu que mon de
vente eu un tu as une pièce où tu
exposes tettey oeuvre d'art est ce que
tu es ce que tu exposes ailleurs est ce
que tu vas dans des faits main ce que tu
vas être que tu as un endroit où il ya
vraiment où les touristes peuvent venir
acheter un marché alors j'ai ici hein je
reçois aussi de temps en temps les gens
aussi à l'atelier
sinon j'ai une espace de vente qui est
au centre ville dans le saint leu dans
le marché couvert de saint leu et je
travaille avec différentes boutiques sur
l'île d'un coude moi je veux je vais
partir je te remercie de nous avoir
accueillis de m'avoir montré un petit
peu rien que la fabrication du bracelet
chauffez la matière pour pouvoir la
halle a donné une forums etc
nicole à la prochaine ben merci merci de
nous montrer un petit peu au public nous
ne dépassons sud nouvelle c'est que les
milliards injectés des meilleurs dans ce
domaine le journal sinon rien super
[Musique]
et qui tient
comment
ouazzani
mon ami et mamies
on a subi là on faire était aussi du
souffleur à saint-leu donc de chou fleur
chou marc hennerici les images parlent
d'elles mêmes je crois que oui je suis
sur la plus belle ville du monde et je
suis très très très chanceux d'être né
ici je vous laisse je vous dis tout
simplement aurevoir à la prochaine et on
n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
pas du tout parce qu'on fait quand on
entre dans l'auberge on peut plus sortir
c'est tellement bien c'était une super
saison géniale des fois tu rends compte
[Musique]